carmel and i uh are here to make a
brief statement and i'm sure we'll have
more to say
later and either tonight or tomorrow
but let me begin by thanking the press
for being here
and thanking everyone else my fellow
americans yesterday
once again proved that democracy
is the heartbeat of this nation jesse
has
has been the heartbeat of this nation
for two centuries
and even in the face of pandemic more
americans voted this election
than ever before in american history
over 150 million people
cast their votes i think that's just
extraordinary
and if we had any doubts we shouldn't
have any longer
about a government of by and for the
people
it's very much alive very much alive in
america
here the people rule
power can't be taken or asserted
it flows from the people and it's their
will
that determines who will be the
president of the united states
and their will alone and now
after a long night of counting it's
clear
that we're winning enough states to
reach 270 electoral votes needed to win
the presidency
i'm not here to declare that we've won
but i am here to report when the count
is finished
we believe we will be the winners
with all the votes counted we have won
wisconsin by 20 000 votes
virtually the same margin that president
trump won
that state four years ago in michigan
we lead by over 35 000 votes
and is growing a substantially bigger
margin
and president trump won michigan in
2016.
michigan will complete its vote soon
maybe as early as the day
and i feel very good about pennsylvania
virtually all the remaining ballots to
be counted were cast by mail
and we've been winning 78 percent of the
votes
by mail in pennsylvania
we flipped arizona and the second
district of nebraska
of special significance to me is that
we've won
with the majority of the american people
and every indication is that the
majority will grow
we have a popular vote lead of nearly 3
million votes
and every indication is that will grow
as well
indeed senator harris and i are on track
to win more votes than any ticket in the
history of this country
that ever won the presidency and vice
presidency
over 70 million votes i'm very proud of
our campaign
only three presidential campaigns in the
past
have defeated an incumbent president
when it's finished
god willing will be the fourth this is a
major achievement
this is a major achievement and it's
been a long and difficult campaign
but it's been a more difficult time
for our country a hard time
we've had a hard campaigns before
we've faced hard times before so once
this election
is finalized and behind us it'll be time
for us to do what we've always done as
americans to put the harsh rhetoric
of the campaign behind us to lower the
temperature
to see each other again to listen to one
another
tweet to hear each other again
and respect and care for one another
to unite to heal
to come together as a nation
i know this won't be easy i'm not naive
neither of us are i know how deep and
hard the opposing views are
in our country on so many things but i
also know this as well
to make progress we have to stop
treating our opponents
as enemies we are not enemies
what brings us together as americans is
so much stronger
than anything that can tear us apart so
let me be clear
i we are campaigning as a democrat
but i will govern as an american
president
the president the presidency itself is
not
a partisan institution it's the one
office
in this nation that represents everyone
and it demands a duty of care for
all americans that is precisely what i
will do
i'll i will work as hard for those who
didn't vote for me
as i will for those who did vote for me
now every vote must be counted
no one's going to take our democracy
away from us
not now not ever america's come
too far america's fought too many
battles
america's endured too much to ever let
that happen
we the people will not be silenced
we the people will not be bullied
we the people will not surrender
my friends i'm confident will emerge
victorious
but this will not be
my victory alone or our victory alone
it'll be a victory for the american
people
for our democracy for america
and there will be no blue states and red
states
when we win just the united states of
america
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops